Hello Mint, it's Major Zero.
Can you hear me?
Major Zero.
Your mission is to infiltrate MGS Con 3, loyalty to the con.
It's not going to be in a hotel basement anymore.
This is a real convention centre, a completely different
jungle.
Panels, artist alley, and even a gaming room.
There's a lot of ground to cover, but first we need you to
lead the charge for the digital convention attendees,
keeping them company.
The fate of the digital stream is in your hands.
The world is watching you.
I accept, but only if we can do a parody of the Metal Gear
Solid 3 opening.
Done.
The plane's outside.
Since the beginning, the convention was split into two,
in-person and digital.
This marked the era known as MGSCon.
A con without borders in a physical and digital space.
Ontario, California for this mission, Mint.
There are over 1,000 people attending this in person this
year and even more watching online.
Throw that thing away, we're over the drop site.
This is MGS Comm 3, a special event among MGS fans.
Please try to make the most of it.
This is one for the history books.
The first Ghost Halo jump.
Godspeed, spread your wisps and fly.
Oh, yippee!